[Musique]
sur la terre est ce qu'il ya plus
d'hommes où plus de femmes plus jeunes
on les a comptés j'ai une pauvre
moi personnellement je crois que les
hommes sont plus aptes ainsi que les
femmes plus apprécié oui je suis pas
quelqu'un qui va en fuyant sociétés
préfèrent les hommes aux femmes
j'ai déjà remarqué ça y'a quoi est ce
combat c'est une petit sourire aux
hommes qu'aux femmes
moi je pense plutôt qu'elle plus de fans
parce que déjà données classiques
chamond y'a pas beaucoup d'hommes qui
des fois de les conférences dans les
conférences de gaz au delà des hommes
mais des récompenses de tuya plutôt plus
de faim il mister ans il travaille alors
on les voit pas quand soudain il ya plus
de femmes ou de copies puisqu'elles vont
toujours en commission moi pour vous ce
que j'aimerais c'est qu'à le même monde
sommes une même nombre de femmes au
conseil en or et chacun aurait un
plus de femmes parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'enfants s'il a une seule femme pour
faire un enfant ça se peut pas il faut
avoir un an par serrano confère à
l'enfant
alors ça veut pas dire qu'il ya plus de
femmes par exemple ça pistoles bas ont
pas beaucoup plus de guerre parce que ça
peut aider mais comment de tous s'il
irait que des femmes sur la terre il n'y
aurait pas de guerre je ne sais pas je
pense à sont raisonnables ci avait que
des femmes elles se disent très peu
disputerait quand même entre elle et
aurait bon cru de cacahouète ses dc10
tutelle bagdad d'axa bien d'autres à
venir la même rengaine est pas oublier
paul lt les voilà avec une chorale comme
ça
bellerose et ses coiffures spéciales
es12 à vie elle se fonde plus belle
possible tandis que les hommes y sont
normaux qui sont pas les yeux sur cuatro
cogepha je me suis mis par tout ce que
tu sais frédéric pourquoi les femmes se
maquillent oui pour qu'elle soit il mêle
radio ni confère aux hommes
bon ce n'est pas grave hein pas
tellement non je préfère être surnaturel
quand on met du rouge à lèvres c'est pas
bien ouej en a un petit peu c'est que ça
fait pas un drame
maj tout comme les femmes se maquille
pas pour seulement pour plaire aux
hommes mais c'est aussi parce qu'elles
sont coquettes ma maman elle met
beaucoup de bleus viennent pas et non
mais pas l'arrêter parce que ça fait un
peu plus féminin son rouge à lèvres tout
ça est ce que les femmes peuvent faire
tout ce que les hommes font
quels sont les métiers qu'elles ne
peuvent pas pratiquer elle va mal c'est
pour qu'on tire déjà le tracteur moi je
suis contre le tracteur elles sont un
petit peu moins habiles pour conduire b
des avions pour faire bien peur je vous
demande pourquoi les hommes se croient
supérieurs aux femmes
est ce que les femmes sont plus
intelligentes que les hommes ou est ce
le contraire
des fois ça se joue des deux si
intelligent mc l'autre que je pense
différemment et la baisse
moi je trouve que les qu'une femme eliza
manque un peu de l'âme intelligent
seulement les hommes en plus de chance
parce qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de droits
qu'une femme c'est vrai dans quels
domaines par exemple chez pas là il ya
20 ans l'arrière les fallait pas ce que
fait le roi du ski et situe tout réservé
tous les hommes kwapis l'asie aussi
presse palois de le voter
mais ça a changé qui s'en chargent
heureusement ce qui reste des choses que
les femmes ne peuvent pas faire et que
les hommes pas je crois puis elles
peuvent pas faire
khelil
[Musique]